hey I was gonna press - vampire we just
hit 39 million bros or subscribers or
people or dinosaurs I feel like we
should be running out of people how can
there be 39 I was happy when I got 39
subscribers I get what do you want Edgar
just not your blog so I just got back
from PAX it was a lot of fun I did a
signing there and it was really cool to
meet you bros it's been such a long time
since I actually went out and met fans
and to hear some of your stories over
how long you've been a fan or a bro and
how much watching my videos has meant to
you to hear that face to face is really
heartwarming it was so nice I really
really enjoyed it and it made me really
excited because in October I will be
doing the book tour so I will be meeting
even more of you bros and I'm really
excited about that and it made me
realize why I love making videos so much
again and it's really thanks to you bros
I owe everything to you at all 39
million of you without you there would
be none of me sitting here doing what I
love to do so thank you and that's why I
wanted to make this video and say thank
you for hitting 39 million with me 39
million that's that's pretty [ __ ]
insane I also want to take this time to
announce another shout out competition
we've done two or three before they are
usually it's such a small thing for me
to do but they usually have had really
big impact on other youtubers YouTube is
such a space where the ones that are on
top it's easy for us but for everyone
else down at the bottom there's so many
talented people they don't usually get
the same kind of shot so we're gonna do
a competition all the rules will be
linked in the description but if you are
youtuber who post videos regularly who
think that you have are unrecognized
then feel free to participate it might
change your life that's disgusting
how dare the [ __ ] lining keeps
changing am either like a [ __ ] son or
super-dark
alright so we have some extra time I'm
gonna answer some of you bros questions
first question how long is your dick you
bros just keep impressing me with your
questions
they're so good why is your hair so oily
sometimes Thanks when was the last time
you pissed yourself probably a few
months months ago I was gonna have pee
but I forgot to take off my pants
struggles of idiots are you sure you
don't want to be a drag queen you wear
women's clothes an awful lot it's cool
if you do
I love drag queens I don't want to be a
drag queen I just like wearing dresses
because I look fabulous
beautify why do dogs pee I don't know
I'm here why do they lick me again
[ __ ] didn't think so
how to be successful in life just like
you oh thank you I feel like a when you
bros watch youtubers you think like we
have the perfect life and like it's so
simple and all that stuff and I don't
want to sound like discouraging I love
my life I wouldn't change anything but
it's not like in any way it's perfect
I'm still I'm still human obviously and
I think a lot of people forget about
that when you watch YouTube they didn't
you just see you never see us in a bad
mood you never see us dealing with
stress and and all that stuff and we
still do alright so calm calm your tips
I'm sure your life is not bad bad it's
just don't compare it to other people's
so much live your own life and [ __ ]
everyone else and just big [ __ ] happy
yes that's a good quote favourite Studio
Ghibli movie Howl's Moving Castle be
when did you get your tattoo and why oh
my god I guess I guess it's time to talk
about the tattoos I've always wanted to
get a tattoo and I just realized I want
to live my life the way I want it now
and not just postpone things because
it's it's such a thing that's so easy to
be like oh I really want to get it
tattoo but I don't know and then you
postpone it and then you never do it
let's be honest that happens a lot and
tattoo was one of those things where I I
just really wanted to get it so I
decided to get it so I got this one I'm
sure you've seen it it's one it's from
one of my favorite artists and then I
got this one which is also from one of
my favorite artists I don't want to talk
too much about um more than that but um
it's cool and I'm probably gonna get
more I know a lot of people like to
judge about tattoos and stuff like that
but I got him for me and it doesn't
matter what you think I'm sorry okay
okay so that was it thank you both so
much for 39 million I can't wait to hit
40 and I'm just so excited to be on this
journey together with you Bruce here's
some 40 million bros stay awesome